plein jour travaillé avec humanité avec
l'heure où les appels de son gardien
c'est devenu leur surnom celui des
travailleurs de la santé offrant souvent
les demandeurs d'asile en attente d'un
statut qui souffrent de ce point de vue
visuel de troisième point c'est pour eux
qu'ils sont allés manifester devant le
bureau de justin trudeau réclamant qu'on
leur donne la résidence permanente
ceux qui sont d'humanité que nos
gouvernements plus appuyé ces gens leur
dire on va mettre enfin à vos
inquiétudes
une vie pour une vie donnée la vie au
québec ils donnent leur vie pour vous
selon la maison d'haïti environ 800
personnes d'origine haïtienne en attente
d'un statut d'immigration travaillant ch
et celle des ou en hôpitaux au québec
c'est quand même important de venir nous
aider et je pense que ça va être
récompensé pour les autres ap avec eux
la situation actuelle on est tellement
mal pris même s'il s'agit d'une
compétence fédérale qui effectivement
très peu ouvert à cette idée d'exception
puisque beaucoup de ces demandeurs
d'asile sont arrivés par le chemin oxame
de façon irrégulière
we cannot open the door to c et few
comme illégales et ifrane jobs date
choqué je pense que c'est une décision
purement politique ce spécialiste en
droit de l'immigration fait partie des
avocats qui réclament aussi cette mesure
exceptionnelle
ce qu'on demande c'est de ne pas
poursuivre la demande d'asile mais
d'aller directement dans la voie
d'accord pour des consultations
on peut faire des exceptions mais j'ai
l'impression qu'une certaine frilosité à
québec qu'à ottawa en ce moment le
député alexandre boulerice parraine une
pétition de plus de 2000 signatures
lancée au parlement ne venez pas nous
dire soit le mode aux trois poumons
rayonnement est officiellement
le gouvernement trudeau ne s'avance pas
si jacques andré charbonneau radio
canada mon frère